Come a little bit closer Hear what I have to say
Just like children we sleep in We could dream this night away
But there's a full moon rising Let's go dancing in the light
We know where the music's playing Let's go out and feel the light Because
I'm still in love with you I wanna see you dance again Because I'm still in love with you On this harvest moon When
we were strangers I watched you from afar But
now it's getting late And the moon is climbing high
I want to celebrate See it shining in your eyes
Because I'm still in love with you I wanna see you dance again Because I'm still in love with you On this harvest moon
Because I'm still in love with you dance again because I'm still in love with you on this harvest moon